I've reached a point in my career, where I
was working with heads of
all the different functional areas in our
business.
I'd never taken a business course in my
life.
I have graduate degrees in psychology.
So I really wanted to deepen my
understanding of those different
functional areas so that I could do my job
and lead my team more effectively.
I found SEP really compelling.
Every minute of it has been so carefully
thought through.
Things that previously I understood in
kind of a superficial level.
I had a much deeper understanding and in
fact I could tell a story to
our investors about what we were doing and
why we were doing it.
In a way that I wasn't able to do
previously.
Innovation is an approach to doing things,
not just an event, or a series of events.
And that was something that crystalized
for me.
Being able to make it real within the
corporate marketing function here at
FICO was really important to me.
SEP was an accellerant not just for me,
but for my whole team.
What I found upon my return to work,
was that my team had really grown a great
deal.
Now we're all operating at a higher level
than we were before and
we are going to continue in this
direction.
SEP was a transformational experience for
me, it gave me the tools and
the language to create more value within
my business, for
myself, for my team, for our organization
and our contributions to society.